howdy he'll reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm John hump we are going to watch
today a video a wonderful channel named
space taste paper Oh hmm this comes from
patron Alex gross one of our reward
tiers on patreon whatever video you
request we must definitely cover the
child Alex gross works on here space
taste they do some awesome awesome
breakdowns with some cool theories and
everything I'm telling you guys like
we've done reactions to two of these
videos Back to the Future is time travel
ethical and The Truman Show the ethics
of fabricated reality is telling you
guys these are good videos there's a lot
of editing put it to them a lot of
thought really good scripts behind them
if you guys can go subscribe to the
channel that'd be great we're subscribed
to them right now too because it's a
really really damn good Channel matter
of fact just watch along with us then
we're gonna talk about this video this
one is gonna be predator is trophy
hunting ethical probably not the
predator does not ethical and it's the
predator believe in a predator I mean it
seems like it's more of a like a sport
hunters that's cooler right yeah yeah
yeah
except trophy hunting predator edition
since the dawn of man
humans have hunted why for the simple
reason of staying alive but yes Solomon
of agriculture in civilized societies
the need for nothing ceased but the wand
stayed there by coining the term trophy
hunting which brought its own bag of
ethical dilemma is this a newfound form
of hunting ethical let's take a look at
the universe's most ferocious fictional
extraterrestrials to find out we all
know how predators don't scale and
redditor hunts humans human attempts to
survive predator most fail oh we spare a
common time again oh but who are
predators well the predator species also
known as the Yahoo Jeff are badass
aliens who hunt other species for sport
and honor that's all they do or at least
that's all I'm here to do human Bray
exotic prey you name it they hunted
predators are said to be descendants of
primitive mammalian ancestors called
their absence that have been removed
from Earth by a greater intelligence to
fulfill their evolutionary potential
although these alien killing resist are
clearly brutal and downright angry I
think that much different than humans
not really
you see does all of us humans they have
a taste for trophy hunting the only real
difference between their trophy hunting
and ours is that rather than hunting
rhinos and other exotic creatures
they're hunting Huff's Oh almost evil
and using our spinal cords and air
trophies saying that critic says nothing
isn't ethical but human trophy hunting
is
[Laughter]
good good editors we're seen as sponsor
beatings and in most ways we are
creditors looking for advanced
sophisticated talk perspective they may
not be the prettiest of creatures to
look at today nobody's perfect you may
be thinking I can't predators be nice
and not kill people in a roof there's
final course you're fun oh that's right
they're bred to do humans on the other
hand here aren't bred to do that or at
least not in our current society so why
do we still hunt well humans hunt for
many reasons some of which are positive
hunting can sometimes be necessary to
survive to protect or even keep
overpopulation in check
after all we are descendants of hunters
and gatherers and without the West
mighty of the success of Agriculture we
would likely revert back to our
primitive roots but right now there's no
need to predator if you've never born to
kill and although they're advanced they
still maintain their primitive roots and
all their own youch a code of honor
which is likely the reason for their
apathy towards efforts a regardless of
what they've done it's time to reveal
what we think is trophy hunting ethical
we say no oh damn animals for the
purpose of the pride and endanger
species that lived on this earth far
longer than we have
that's what makes their body so value
let us know in the comments below and
we'll see you soon
I am opposed to trophy hunting I'm not
convinced yeah order and watch the video
about predators not talk about freaking
trophy I don't want to think I don't
want to talk about real issues in my
life right now I want to bring home a
mallard predator jaws real yeah tell me
stop hunting in Africa you mean I gotta
remove all my taxidermy rhinos skulls
damn yeah what am I gonna do this summer
value in my life choice no I don't think
it's ethical no I feel I think it's a
terrible terrible thing especially when
there are the animals that are like on
the verge of extinction see me I hunt
chickens because they keep reproducing
them yeah I mean there are tons and tons
and tons of chickens yeah sometimes
they're just out there in the
neighborhoods honestly you don't even
need to hunt them
nobody's gravan oh now this matter now
that we have arguably unethical means of
storing many animals in one place yeah
you could just walk through and be like
Punk
I want the comments a kind look you
hypocrite but you read meat yeah that's
the same that's the same as well killing
a [ __ ] cheetah I mean there's a whole
other debate to be happy yeah I don't
come over to I don't like make people
come over and be like hey check out
these chickens I shot and also like I'm
gonna mount their heads but do you want
a sandwich to the whole point of trophy
hunting in my eyes is to be like hey you
see that I murdered that yeah check me
out or hey I bought that yeah somebody
else murdered that for me not even a lot
of money and that's why they see that
dead thing that says something about me
that's just something about my prowess
in the outdoor but the thing is to like
nowadays hunting has changed so much
this is super unfair I would understand
the argument in favor of trophy hunting
like six percent more if we didn't have
all these like climb up a tree have no
scent have like a laser-guided scope so
you can shoot an animal from five
hundred yards away at that point you
didn't have to try you just sit there
and wait for an animal to come and
that's gonna happen you know I like this
video though cuz I did bring up a point
I think that much different than humans
some other predator movies address the
whole theme of it is that we're hunters
and then you know like the predator
habits that come across humans that are
also hunters and that concept of we do
that we've accepted it as a normal thing
what if something that views us is just
one of those animals comes along and
decides to hunt us that's like a cool
theme that I don't think the predator
movies ever really explore and all that
well the one that did it best is the
first movie in terms of Arnold as a
hunter that's the exact table is being a
hunter but clearly some kind of hunting
tracking tracking trapping he has the
skills of a hunter hence one in that
finale when they go toe-to-toe with each
other it's really engaging because
you're watching hunter versus hunter at
that moment and who is really the hunted
yes but I don't think the movies really
explore that theme in a philosophical
way as as well as this video posed that
question I wish one could because like
part of the thing about like a movies
such as The Texas Chainsaw Massacre is
that there are a lot of parallels in
that original movie - like
slaughterhouses and and things like that
and you don't even necessarily think
about it the first time around but when
you go back it's all there yeah you know
we keep insisting on dredging up the
predator franchise to keep it going like
I would love to have one that at least
touches on a theme like that a bit more
yeah because face a springs up a good
point and what I like their videos
because they're they do sci-fi
breakdowns and I think the predator
movies they're sci-fi one of my favorite
ingredients of sci-fi is when you
explore questions like that the science
paper yeah the themes and everything of
it and I feel like the predator movies
don't ever do that it's like you have
the hunting you might have a line or two
that establishes they're hunters and
were the prey predator that's a sports
center what we do the movie
predators cool right you don't really
have this idea of but is what they're
doing really all that bad if we do that
yeah it's a world we hunt animals we
view as lesser they have us as lesser
animals so who's disliked they can't
what course that's bad yeah yeah of
course of course
but a movie to explore the debate of
that would be cool if they shouldn't be
doing that to us then perhaps we
shouldn't be doing that yeah that
predator movie ends where we all become
vegans yeah exist with the Predators we
all become vegans but then you get that
like last moment gotcha where it zooms
out to reveal that we're all just in a
free-range pen has some kind of
slaughterhouse waiting to become like
predator burgers or something yes fine
cut human steaks yeah I mean rockhoppers
are called Atari into Mamba yeah I don't
I don't read the predator comics and
everything that people think existed
before the first predator yocha yocha
yeah kombucha yocha
ever made this or whatever they expand
the premises or after that movie it was
just like they call it yahoo ch we just
smell Yahoo cha different word got me
more about the predator franchises lower
than any predator I've ever seen I think
yeah this is some fictional this isn't
some real word they were just like Yahoo
yeah that's the best part about making
up a species is you could just call it
whatever you want some real language if
you feel like it and and there you have
it you've got a lower I know we're
pissing off someone who sounds like what
does a burger say in his head when he
shoots somebody Yamcha got a me in this
case I wouldn't be mad to get some
diehards in the comments just to know
that somebody cares enough about
predator to be aware of all this oh
we've got and you've gotten some
messages really about predators
specifically yeah there's some guy on
our facebook who just messages us all
the time when he's mad at us you don't
understand the predator yeah I don't
know his name and I just told him he's
wasting his time in the grand scheme but
I'll still see his inbox just like leave
me alone I don't care game of life I'm
gonna know a lot about a few things and
a little about a lot of things be glad I
know something about any of this I don't
think trophy hunting is ethical but your
video made me do is really think like it
well if you're gonna do a predator movie
explore that theme throughout because
that is something [ __ ] new and I just
appreciate you exploring all these
different pop-culture things through the
scope of ethics you know I think that's
a nice thing to add to the conversation
I hope more people start watching the
videos man every video we've seen the
ethic answer is no how is there anything
that is ethical Alex come on man we need
a yes episode once in a while to keep
[ __ ] interesting alright guys well you
can subscribe to space tastes you guys
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell what would you
want to see done in a new
predator movie comment below and check
us on patreon we have TV show reactions
QA days and John's doing music video
coverage weekly so go check us out